herr präsident meine damen und herren
ich bilde mir nicht ein die mehrheit für
dieses gesetz in diesem haus mit einer
rede noch zu verändern
und wenn ich da bisher zweifel gehabt
hat hat die rede von herrn brinkhaus mir
deutlich gemacht dass die regierenden
nicht bereit sind irgendetwas einzusehen
zu festgezurrt trinkaus ist der wille
der regierenden mit untauglichen mitteln
die pandemie zu bekämpfen als das
einreden der opposition die ja nicht nur
von uns kommen ihren angriff auf die
freiheitsrechte den föderalismus wie den
gesunden menschenverstand noch stoppen
können
wenn der kollege brinker aus wie am
freitag geschehen gegenargumente des
kollegen lindner als politische
profilierung auf kosten von kranken und
toten bezeichnet ist jede sachliche
auseinandersetzung zu ende und das
moralisieren an die stelle von politik
getreten herr brinker aus merken sie
sich das bitte mal
sie stecken in ihren schützengräben fest
und werfen der opposition dysfunktion
vor
aber diese destruktive geht von jenen
aus die in der impfstoff beschaffung
versagt haben
die ihr multilaterales europe ihre
multilaterale europa ideologie wichtiger
nehmen als den lebensschutz der vielen
die auf den eid der bundeskanzlerin
vertraut haben schaden von diesem volke
abzuwenden frau bundeskanzlerin
impfstoff zu beschaffen wo immer es
welchen zu beschaffen gibt ganz gleich
welche geopolitischen verwerfungen damit
verbunden sind damit hausärzte
betriebsärzte und wir auch immer dazu in
der lage ist patienten zu impfen
wollen sie das erste mal in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik die
freiheitsrechte des grundgesetzes
einschränken
nein das ist kein quatsch das ist
tatsache
und statt so viel wie möglich bewegung
an frischer luft zu ermöglichen wie es
in monologen und arioso forscher
empfehlen wird aufgrund einer inzidenz
die jederzeit manipulierbar ist das
öffentliche leben still gestellt was sie
zu beginn versäumt haben sollen nun
beschränkungen zu lasten der menschen
richten was das an kollateralschäden für
die gesellschaft bedeutet hat meine
kollegin weiter bei der einbringung
dieses gesetzes dargestellt mir bleibt
nur warnen darauf hinzuweisen dass hier
ein experiment ausprobiert wird von dem
manche hoffen man könne es bei anderen
gelegenheiten wiederholen
wenn die bundeskanzlerin davon spricht
dass mit dem virus nicht zu verhandeln
ist so werden wir bald hören dass auch
mit dem klima nicht zu verhandeln ist
und die einschränkungen von heute auch
für die schöne neue welt von morgen
taugen
meine damen und herren der publizist
heribert prantl weiß gott kein freund
der afg sagt er fürchte dass die
aktuellen grundrechts einschränkungen
als blaupause verwendet werden für das
nächste virus für den nächsten
katastrophenfall
denn wo man nicht verhandeln kann gibt
es nur eine einzige sprache der
entschlossenheit
schließlich geht es immer ums ganze um
die weltgesundheit das weltklima eben
das überleben der menschheit
dann kann man endlich aufhören
gesellschaftliche ziele und die
politischen wege dorthin in den
parlamenten in der öffentlichkeit zu
diskutieren und stattdessen gleich zur
tat schreiten was sie mit dem gesetz
nach thun im grunde lassen sich für
jeden bereich für fast jeden bereich der
politik ins tänzen quoten oder zielwerte
festlegen deren erreichen entschlossene
und vor allem unverhandelbare maßnahmen
erforderlich machen
wir werden uns bei der klimapolitik
wiedersehen an die stelle der
langwierigen politischen willensbildung
im kleinen tritt die objektive
notwendigkeit entschlossenen handelns im
großen und die altmodische trennung von
regierungen opposition verwandelt sich
in den scharfen gegensatz von
vernünftigen und querulanten aber die
die da draußen protestieren sind nicht
alles querulanten
sie können nicht das halbe volk zu peru
landen
meine damen und herren
aber genau das die einschränkung unserer
grundrechte für wie auch immer
begründete ihre politische ziele wollten
wir nach den erfahrungen zweier
diktaturen in der deutschen geschichte
nie mehr zulassen
meine damen und herren die grundrechte
sind abwehr rechte des bürgers gegen den
staat
der staat ist immer übergriffig das ist
seine natur
deswegen wurden die grundrechte
geschaffen die grundrechte stehen nicht
noch nicht
unser pandemie und klima vorbehalten ich
hoffe das bleibt auch so wenn ich ihre
argumentation sehe weiß ich dass es
nicht so bleiben wird
deshalb ist dieses gesetz ein tabubruch
auch wenn sie versucht haben die
giftzähne am ende ein wenig
abzuschleifen und im bundestag nicht
ganz außen vor zu lassen
meine damen und herren die belastung und
überlastung des gesundheitssystems wäre
ein richtiger maßstab politischen
handelns als die nur vorgeblich
objektive instanz allerdings für die
frage in welcher ordnung wir leben
wollen
taugt er so wenig wie die magische 100
oder 165 oder 200 ihres gesetzes
deswegen lehnen wir das gesetz ab und
erbringt aus das ist eine politische
auseinandersetzung mit dem wort von der
fratze haben sie sich selber dekoriert
wenn solche debatten geführt werden die
sie
hören hat das mit politik nichts mehr zu
tun
es ist nur noch moral knabberei ich
bedanke mich